the grammys will be live from las vegas
for the first time ever yeah the show is
going to be at mgm grand on april 3rd
and the audience is back 8 news now
spoke to celo greene ahead of the awards
show about what to expect christian
casares now with that story
ceelo green is a singer rapper and
record producer who has made a career
out of crossing genres of music he is
also no stranger to music's biggest
night he has won five grammys and has
been nominated 18 times and i just
remember being just excited like i only
got a cool new outfit made all leather
and fur and i was looking cool and i
have a pretty young thing
and we you know we did the red carpet
and
i wasn't disappointed at all it was
great i was just happy to be
acknowledged as former song of the year
winner the bigger question is who does
he think will take it home this year i
feel like it's going to be a toss-up
between peaches and kiss me more dozier
cat and i may even go with those a cat
on this one but ceelo does think there
is a generation gap between when he grew
up in the 90s and the current crop of
young artists taking music by storm as
we evolve sometimes we lose sight of you
know of things that are should remain in
your heart historically you know i mean
but i'm just one of those admirers of
you know art and industry and culture
and as for those young artists we're
talking about billy eilish and olivia
rodrigo they're both nominated in the
big four categories this year either
could pull off a rare quadruple win